so I'm going to play some videos for you
of interviews with CPAC attendees Trump
supporters at the Texas CPAC conference
that took place over the weekend
remember why do we care about the
attendees without supporters the current
Republican movement which is trumpism
would just be Trump in a room yelling
and there would nobody there would be
nobody there so you have to understand
that the attendees give us insight into
why Trump was even able to win okay so
let's get right into it let's get into
uh some of these uh very very strange
interviews here we go they should pay
attention to their children and what
they say when they come home from school
don't criticize listen if there's things
that go against what they've been
teaching their children then they need
to go to a school board meeting we all
need to okay so understand that
this is why Republicans win okay
these are people
at the conference
and as wacky as their beliefs are they
understand the way to win is you get
involved at your local school board now
I'm not saying Democrats don't get
involved at the local school board but
what I am saying
is Republicans have been so much better
than democrats for so long at working at
all of these levels really strongly they
control all sorts of state and local
Boards of Education that's how they get
this crazy nonsense in school and into
classrooms they they do know what
they're doing in that sense in a way
that I've not seen uh Democrats do well
let's listen to some more
supposed to be enforced
there's a way to fight back and the way
to do it is use your words and use your
money go to your schools don't send your
kid to an indoctrination camp on College
use your money email the alumni of the
schools email the donors say this is
what they're teaching my kids in school
I think the way we can combat It Is by
parents really knowing what's being
taught in the schools I don't know that
passing laws do any good at all
generally a lot of the laws that are
passed are either ignored or creates
anger
but we have to get rid of the critical
theory being on school boards uh getting
into elected offices so that you know
what the curriculum is that is being
taught this is how they have
successfully done what Democrats have
been unable to do for a really long time
so that's one side of CPAC this is like
the old school CPAC these people
actually do know how to organize in the
real world online stuff they're actually
terrible they really are terrible with
the online stuff but they know exactly
what they're doing there now here is the
cartoonish side here are some interviews
right side broadcasting network did this
is the other side and the wacky people
that show up let's take a look here hey
how you doing hey Mike Mike with right
side yeah so Latinos for Trump right so
talk a little about Latinos for Trump
what do you think president Trump's
going to be saying here you have a trump
2024 shirt I think he's going to be
running here absolutely I think so yes
what do you think his message is going
to surround hey what do you want to hear
him say the most besides that he's
running
um that we are not going to let our
country fall to Communism I was very
excited when
that is that listen we've been covering
this for for months for years this is
what the Republican party now is what
she wants to hear from Trump it's not
about how am I going to put money in
your pocket how am I going to get you
health care how are we going to fix
infrastructure it's
um how are we going to stop communism
there's no threat of Communism in the
United States there's no there's no risk
that the United States will become a
communist country their messaging is
nuts but these people seem to have
accepted it hook line and sinker
um president Trump started talking about
socialism because no one was having that
conversation even though we were seeing
it happen in all of our communities wow
no one was having that conversation they
didn't want to say call it what it is
it's communism then we have a lot what's
communism what is communism
organizations here in the state of Texas
that our um like our people's project or
Texas organizing project it sounds you
know the way they word it you know but
it's it's worded in such a way where or
you wouldn't say or think that that is a
communist org and they are running
Communists on the Democratic ballot here
in the state of Texas So This Woman's
completely wrong about the facts of
everything that's going on but it's been
very very effective and they don't care
about policy so when we say oh
at some point don't they have to get
back to policy
not really because if they can just go
with fear of Communism that doesn't
exist they don't really need to go back
to that here's another example next
person they interviewed of they
understand the importance of going local
thank you Jen appreciate it
what uh sure sure yeah
I am California
and um I'm an activist and uh I believe
in what we're saying here about getting
involved and stuff but I think we forget
to mention that how we're going to do
that we need to get back into the
neighborhoods we need to do in
California right now we are organizing
uh precincts and voter registration yes
we're not talking about voter
registration I I think that's actually
that's a great point I'm glad you can
they get it guys they get it and so as
cartoonish as these people are
the they can keep winning stuff they can
keep what they the local uh element here
they get it here's one more here's a
homeschooler that they ran into and you
brought your daughter along so so Karen
talk about your experience feedback why
are you here what did you hope to get
out of it and we're towards the end now
so what are your final thoughts well I'm
absolutely blown away I mean this this
is our first CPAC and I decided to bring
my I'm a homeschool mom so I I
homeschool my three kids and so this is
basically part of their education right
now homeschooling okay the most common
reason that people homeschool in the U.S
is because they want a safe School
environment that's 25 now what does that
mean they're not talking about physical
safety when they mean safe they mean
safe from indoctrination that they
believe is taking place that's 25 of
homeschoolers say that's why they're
homeschooling 21 of homeschoolers are
doing it to teach kids their religious
and moral views
these are overwhelmingly conservative
Christians okay that's the homeschooling
movement that's the element there's huge
overlap between the Christian
homeschoolers and the anti-vaxxers
there's a huge overlap between the
Christian homeschoolers and the
right-wing conspiracy theorists so right
away hitting all the highlights of these
folks let's continue
I brought Charlotte she's 14 with me
it's it's been amazing
great people I feel at home finally I'm
from California so it's a little tough
right there sometimes that's why she
homeschools she's because she wants her
daughter around people like the ones
that go to CPAC but um and I appreciate
you guys so much for all you do we
actually can find the rallies and we can
find all the the True News here so it's
been wonderful so so and Charlotte so
you are 14 years old right and this is
probably your first political event
right so so what what have your thoughts
been on the last couple days it's been
insane it's been pretty overwhelming but
it's been really cool like seeing
everyone and meeting everyone I
especially liked when Trump had people
chant lock her up about Hillary so who
who is your favorite person that you've
met have you met any Congress people
politicians when Lauren bobert said no
vaccines I thought that was so proud so
I was so proud of that it was so great
meet anybody like that we met Matt and
Mercedes slap you're really kind to us
and it was really cool to meet them
amazing like I said earlier the great
thing about CPAC is that Grassroots
people people who just love this country
so there it is really horrifying stuff
at CPAC but these people vote they won
in 2016. they almost won in 2020 and we
have a really big uphill battle in 2022
and 2024 upcoming after the break we'll
talk about the CPAC straw poll winner uh
and a bunch of other stuff we'll have
more on this on the show's Instagram
find it at davidpakman show on Instagram
oh by the way follow me I showed people
my eggplant over the weekend on my
Instagram david.pakman it's my first
eggplant and you can find that on my uh
my Instagram quick break back after this
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries from
the world's best filmmakers and right
now curiosity stream is giving you 25
off which comes out to just 14.99 a year
curiosity stream has a bigger selection
of documentaries than Netflix Hulu or
Amazon I'm always finding documentaries
on curiosity stream that I can't find
anywhere else and they always have the
newest and most critically acclaimed
titles I just finished watching autonomy
which is all about self-driving vehicles
and emerging technology that's going to
have a big impact on our economy on our
political system I can watch curiosity
stream on all of my devices they have
documentaries on politics economics
history technology psychology you name
it and when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman my audience
will get 25 off that makes it 14.99 a
year not a lot of money for the amount
of enjoyment that I know you will get
from Curiosity stream and the link is
right underneath this video